[Applause]
times definitely an opinion section
writer our good friend Barry Weiss
[Music]
[Applause]
okay well thank you for being here I
know it was not easy I mean we've never
really had a segment like this where we
had a guest on who was recently back
from a terrorist attack on their
hometown and when I heard about what
happened in Pittsburgh I know two people
from Pittsburgh my head writer and you I
remember you at the Mets game with your
Pittsburgh Pirates yeah and I first
thought oh I hope they weren't involved
but how did the chances chances were
pretty good yeah it was the synagogue
where I was but MIT's food
my dad was president was the leader of
one of the congregation's that met there
for many years and he personally knew
five of the eleven innocent people who
were murdered you did I read your story
today you talked about people who you
saw every week I did I talked about a
man named Cecil Rosenthal who was killed
along with his brother David Rosenthal
you know one of the most evil things
about the nature of this act is that the
murderer killed the most innocent good
stalwart people in the community David
and Cecil Rosenthal were both
intellectually disabled but they were
sort of the unofficial mayors of my
neighborhood my mom went to grade school
with them she was constantly giving them
rides to the grocery store and they were
uh sure's in this community and they
would always sort of stand at the
doorway to the sanctuary which is where
they were killed so I know a lot of
people at a thing like time like this
say this is an attack on all religions
right Kellyanne Conway said that a lot
of people say that it's a common thing
on even on the left it's a it's a good
thing they say like you know hope right
there's a desire to make things and
let's let's take it from the most
well-intentioned place a desire to sort
of universalize things and there is
attack on all religions at time sure
this was an attack on Jews and that is a
specific thing in history that is
different right this was an attack by
someone who said that there's a [ __ ]
manifestation in this country who hated
this particular synagogue because of the
incredible values that it stood for the
previous Sabbath's it had been refugee
Shabbat a celebration of the refugee
which is a profound
deep Jewish value one that we pride
ourselves on and this is what made this
this yes I mean this is a guy who didn't
like Trump because he wasn't enough of
an [ __ ] exactly sure he was too much
of a global but he's definitely heard
his message he definitely heard Trump's
message that the invasion is coming and
what I learned recently is that I think
from your article is that when we heard
that chant
in charlottesville Jews will not replace
us I thought they were talking about a
Jew will replace me specifically they
were talking there are such conspiracy
theorists they were talking about the
fact that Jews will not replace us with
the brown people they pulled the strings
they do the hiring
they run the world but they walk but the
but Jews are going to replace us not
themselves
it's the Mexicans are gonna take your
job right what's important to remember
is that anti-semitism is not just a
prejudice it's a conspiracy theory right
it says that there is a secret hand
controlling the world and that secret
hand is called the Jew so even if Trump
himself is not an anti-semite and I
don't believe that he is an anti-semite
he is inculcating an atmosphere of
conspiracy minded thinking yeah so when
he says things like enemies of the
people
globalists you know we can go on and on
it's been happening every day for two
years what in the mind of people like
Richard Spencer and David Duke they hear
Jude yuju and it's not a surprise that
people like that were drawn to Trump's
banner now you have it on the left to
where Israel comes to replace Jew as the
sort of diabolical controller of all the
world's ills right but in this case you
know obviously this person was coming
from the political right yeah they use a
lot of those kind of terms like
globalist or they mention international
bankers and they show George Soros and
they show
yelling and they show people who are
Jewish and I don't think these folks who
follow this think too much past that
they want to believe that anyway and
I've never
understood really why it is the Jews is
it difficult but long how long do we
have on the show well I mean well I
guess it goes back to they think you
know the killing of the Christ is that
is that really where it all comes that's
one strand of it then there's another
strand on the LA I mean it's successful
people don't like success sure I mean
the thing that is interesting about it
right is that typical bigotry it's that
the subject of your bigotry is subhuman
with Jews they are both inhuman and anti
human at once they're both physically
weak and aggressive they are both the
Socialists and the arch capitalists that
is what is so hard about anti-semitism I
think the thing that you know one thing
that I'm grateful for this week is that
oftentimes Jews because they are so
successful in this country and we've had
we have had incredible freedoms and it's
been sort of a singular experience the
Jewish life in America people don't
realize that Jews are 2% of the
population in this country but they make
up half of all hate crimes according to
the FBI in New York City you know half
of the hate crimes this past year were
perpetrated against Jews they're very
small population in the world only about
15 million or something in Israel is a
very small country it bothers me I'm
sure it bothers you that they get so
much hate from the left you know I've
said this before but I'll repeat it I
don't understand how after world war two
people talked about how the Jews they
just went to their slaughter they were
so weak and then Israel became strong
they didn't like that either nope
maybe it's something with the Jews
themselves perhaps Israel's did you
among the nations yes and they shouldn't
apologize for being strong and sometimes
they have to do nasty things that strong
countries have to do like any other
country does but if we went back to free
access we'd go back to pizza parlors
blowing up every week if they had a
truly free West Bank I mean where they
didn't involve themselves at all how
long before the mas Iran weapons but the
problematic thing happening in this
moment right is that people like Steve
Bannon like Israel for the wrong reasons
okay and we don't you've Angelico's do
exactly so because when the world ends
right the Jews convert or die right your
choice one thing that I think one thing
that I think was made stark this week is
that there are many Jews including Jews
that I know who have liked many of
trumps policies regarding Israel the
Middle East they love the fact that the
embassy was moved to Jerusalem the move
that I supported they like the scuttling
of the Iran deal but I hope this week
that American Jews have woken up to the
price of that bargain they have traded
policies that they like for the values
that have sustained the Jewish people
and frankly this country for forever
welcoming the stranger dignity for all
human beings equality under the law
respect for dissent love of truth these
are the things that we are losing under
this president and no policy is worth
that price
so
so that's a pretty good that's a pretty
good speech to the people of your
generation who we worry or may not be
voting
I read that sixty five percent of
Millennials are fearful of the future
and I want to say to them well there's
something you can do about that
do you want our future to be American
carnage or do you want our future to be
a renewal of what the founders talked
about we can be the new Jerusalem again
we can renew the tree of liberty and
this week woke me up to that in a way
that nothing in the past two years ever
has and I God forbid it would come to
your neighborhood but when you see
people you love going through this it
changes you and you realize that the way
we live in this country it is an
aberration in history it's a miracle and
it can go away like that
we have the responsibility to protect it
and we need to elect people to Congress
and everywhere else on Tuesday that are
going to protect those values
very wise